what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
here at comics explained we ask the real
questions the hard-hitting questions a
really good example during daredevil
season 2 if that season took place over
the course of a few weeks or a few
months who was cutting the Punishers
hair because his hair style never
changed it was always the same maybe
he's just really good at cutting his own
hair I have no idea but I have seen you
guys asking questions like hey Rob
haven't you covered some of this stuff
before yes but this is all part of the
bigger picture what you guys don't know
and what you'll find down in the comment
section is a link to a playlist that
I've made where I'm basically going
through all these stories that lead into
Avengers and new Avengers and then
eventually Secret Wars now we covered
Secret Wars I love the way I did those
videos those aren't gonna change those
are just be thrown in which I'll
probably fill them in by the time you
see this this video however Jonathan
Hickman Avengers and new Avengers which
covers the collapse of the multiverse I
did not like those videos and so those
videos are going to be finished they're
gonna be added and sort of you know
remastered and that kind of a thing but
we're also gonna do is we're gonna go in
and we're gonna cover the entire Thanos
chronology leading into infinity Wars so
that's gonna be a great big huge thing
that goes on of course that's an
addition to all the Marvel generations
more of a legacy and all those stories
that I absolutely love and have had a
chance to cover yet so we are at this
point where we are dealing with Ironman
versus the Hulk now those are the guys
who have been around my channel for a
long time who saw this with this video
when it first got popped up bear with me
for a second because we have a lot of
new folks to the world of comics
explained when it came to Hulk vs. Iron
Man this came out of an event called
original sin and when it comes to Marvel
comics you have different types of
events really you have two main events
you have events where it's just crazy
things happen and then the bad guy gets
beat and that's it then you have events
where Marvel uses that as a way to
catapult new characters or existing
characters into new stories Avengers vs.
x-men for example was a way to begin the
process of bringing back the mutant
population in Marvel Comics restoring
the Phoenix force elevating the
character of Hope Summers the first
mutant born after the events of house of
M original sin served the purpose of
basically providing or introducing new
characters original send out with this
story where who want to The Watcher this
being in the Marvel Universe that sees
and essentially knows all was basically
killed by some mysterious person now we
didn't know who that
was initially we later found out that it
was classic Nick Fury of course this
massive battle ensued between Nick
theory and basically the Avengers Nick
Fury told for that Gore was right
Thor lost the ability to wield his
hammer all these different things
started cropping up with all these
different characters the result is that
Marvel grabbed those things and started
bringing in new stories for example when
Marvel acquired the rights to Angela a
character who is a spawn villain they
used original sin to reveal that she was
the sister that Thor and Loki never knew
about the result is that her character
was rolled into Marvel Comics came up
and guardians of the galaxy had a few
titles of her own and that was really
about it but all this came out of a
villain named Eeyore who was one of the
most irrelevant villains ever grabbing
one of the eyes of the watcher and
blasting all these secrets to the
superheroes who were present the result
is that all these memories began to
basically just spray across everyone and
so what original sin Iron Man versus
Hulk did isn't allowed Marvel to come
back and say hey here is a part of the
incredible Hulk's origin that you never
knew about this is and every sense of
the word a red conk retroactive
continuity if you're new here that
basically means that a writer comes in
and changes something from the way that
it used to be or adds something in that
wasn't there before in this instance
we're adding a new dynamic to the origin
of the Incredible Hulk and so again this
is really kind of a cool scenario
because what this does is it initially
opens up with Bruce Banner and Ironman
just beating the crap out of one another
The Incredible Hulk just absolutely
wrecking Iron Man now the basis behind
this actually ends up coming out of all
these different things with regards to
the ongoing Incredible Hulk story and
that's one of the reasons why if you
were following all my Incredible Hulk
videos we followed him chronologically
and then we stopped because what I
wanted to do was use this story as a way
to segue into the next stage of
Incredible Hulk this also basically
gives us a flashback to the early days
of Bruce banners life now something else
to point out here is that this invokes
something called extremis now extremis
was this whole thing that we talked
about when we did the Iron Man's story
of the same name by Warren Ellis of
course you'll find that down in the
comment section of that that huge
playlist that we have it's like 84
videos right now it's nuts with
extremists it was basically this virus
that had been coated to directly impact
human genome but this virus could be
modified in a litany of different ways
the problem with this was that the ease
of adjusting it is what allowed so many
villains to use it and it's really what
allowed all these stories with the
extremists says extremist tech just kind
of going absolutely nuts and going
haywire and so the result of this is
that there was a story with the
Incredible Hulk where Bruce Banner was
shot in the head because there was this
crazy fanatical group that believed he
was gonna cause this extinction level
event the result was that with Bruce
Banner being shot in the head eventually
he was brought to twenty stark and
extremist was used to basically heal him
and so again that's where you know Bruce
Banner stands in the modern day but back
in the past this all goes back to Bruce
Banner basically proposing the gamma
bomb to the United States military now
of course this also goes into the early
days of Bruce Banner first encountering
general Thunderbolt Ross different
things like that
but the idea is that where Bruce Banner
intended to use the gamma bomb as a
means to show that gamma radiation could
be used to basically heal all sorts of
ailments and illnesses out there the
u.s. military didn't care about that
what the US military cared about is that
this was going to be the next generation
of warfare and so the idea is that as
long as they are a step ahead as long as
the world's using nuclear weapons and
suddenly the US has a gamma bomb which
is thousands of times more powerful than
a nuclear weapon no one's going to
attack the u.s. and so because of this
where the US military only cares about
the weapons use banners argument is that
this can be used for so much more and so
this is the quintessential example of an
argument between an idealist and really
just weapons manufacturing now of course
this inevitably brings in Tony Stark now
20 starts not necessarily invited here
he's just kind of there but the idea is
that as the world's leading weapons
manufacturer it makes sense that he
would be here but where he looks at this
whole bomb the way it's been designed by
Bruce Banner and while he's just kind of
in a drunken state and just being a dick
he's basically saying look banner
designed this bomb so that it wouldn't
explode in the same capacity so it's
really not living up to its full
destructive potential
now of course banner responds by saying
the basis behind this was to insure the
bomb could demonstrate a use in terms of
practical you know applications for
bettering humanity more so than just
destroying things now the cool thing
about this is that this had always
really been banners perspective Bruce
Banner had always looked around to the
world and said let's find ways to make
it better this perspective
began to shift when he became The
Incredible Hulk and the reason why is
because of the fact that as The
Incredible Hulk Banner was fighting a
war on two sides on one side it was
people who were pursuing him for a
litany of reasons because they wanted to
harness the power of the Incredible Hulk
because I wanted to use Bruce Banner and
the Hulk for their own ends at the same
time it was fighting a war against the
Avengers the Fantastic Four the x-men
the superhero community trying to get
them to believe that he was a guy that
could be trusted
but even in the eyes of Bruce Banner all
those superheroes out there looked at
him as just a means to an end but when
it really hits the fan let's just call
him the Hulk because he's the one that
can solve the problems more often than
not he would show up he would beat the
hell out of the bad guy and the day
would be saved but banner developed a
lot of resentment over the years because
he saw himself just simply being used as
a means to an end and so in truth a lot
of these things were coming to a head
now of course with this focusing almost
exclusively on the whole idea of you
know Bruce banners early history because
Tony Stark is going through and learning
about these different things because
he's been blasted or at least been
forced to basically remember these
things that he had long since forgotten
the result is that Bruce Banner is
experiencing the same thing and so what
this is is basically a race to confirm
this information they're all standing in
front of the orb who's got one of the
eyes of the watcher during original sin
the orb lasts the entire superhero
community that's present with the
memories or with everything the Watchers
ever seen
suddenly the you know Ironman realizes
oh my god I think I'm the one that made
the Incredible Hulk the way he was by
messing with his gamma bomb he's on a
race to figure out whether or not he
actually did at the same time Bruce
Banner is blasted with this realization
that Tony Stark is supposedly messed
with the gamma bomb and he's checking to
see if this is actually true now these
are inevitably going to lead to one
another and the reason why is because
it's essentially Tony Stark trying to
basically play defense with you know the
Incredible Hulk playing offense did Tony
Stark really screw me over Tony Stark
did I really screw Bruce Bruce Banner
over it but for one of these guys the
truth is more terrifying for them than
it is for the other now of course again
what we end up finding out is that
because of the fact that Tony Stark had
you know made this great big huge speech
in front of Bruce Banner to general
Thunderbolt Ross and these members of
the US military about how the bomb was
basically being decreased and
destructive capabilities by Bruce Banner
suddenly tony stark's called in by
general Thunderbolt Ross hey are you
willing to pick up the slack the result
is that Tony Stark begins the process of
meddling with the bond now something
else this does is it brings in Arno
stark Arno Stark is basically this
brother of Tony Stark
that he never knew about and in fact
what we ended up learning is that Arno
Stark was for all intents and purposes
engineered to be the smartest man in the
world the idea here is that Arno
basically resides within the iron
metropolitan this massive
technologically advanced city that Tony
Stark and Arnold built together under
the hopes that they could usher in this
new era of peace now of course this led
to iron man more or less abandoning the
project really kind of going back to the
world of being a superhero and leaving
Arno to run it's something that he was
more than able to do but with Bruce
Banner knowing this what he basically
does is quote unquote overdose on
extremists the result is that when this
happens and he collapses he's
immediately met by a message from Arno
now of course through spanner begins to
put on this ruse oh yeah man the
extremest tech is acting kind of weird
I gotta sort it out I got a good I think
I know what the problem is all I need
for you to do is fix it for me so again
this is really Bruce Banner playing into
our no because remember Arno is pretty
new on the scene all he knows about
Bruce Banner all he knows about these
heroes is what he's seen on the news but
he does not know about them personally
all Arno knows is that Bruce Banner was
shot in the head at some point the
extremest Tech is what helped him
suddenly Bruce Banner passes out and he
says hey there's something wrong with
the extremest Tech and Arno says ok I'll
fix it for you that's it that's what's
going on between these two guys but it's
cool because it's really Bruce Banner
just kind of ensuring the idea that he's
basically going to be able to do
whatever it is that he needs to do the
problem with this is that when Bruce
Banner shows up to Stark mansion when
Arno begins using the extremest tech to
basically go through and quote-unquote
fix the problem that Bruce Banner
pointed out Bruce Banner immediately
morphs into the Incredible Hulk but this
is not the regular Incredible Hulk this
is not Savage Hulk
this is a guy named green now this is
not the first time that we've seen a
character like this back in 1991 during
his massive run on the character writer
Peter David wrote a story that basically
saw the Incred
Hulk gray Hulk and Bruce Banner merged
into a singular being of course this was
Incredible Hulk issue number 377 but
this was basically a guy that most fans
referred to as the professor and the
idea here was that this version of The
Incredible Hulk was extremely smart this
is the same version of The Incredible
Hulk that you saw if you manage to read
future imperfect it was maestro Hulk
versus like that merged quote-unquote
professor Hulk with this version it's
much the same way but the difference
here is that this is the Incredible Hulk
basically modified with extremists tech
the idea here is that in this instance
this version of The Incredible Hulk is
extremely smart is as smart basically
has the capacities of Bruce Banner it
also has all the memories of Bruce
Banner and so what this means is that
where Banner was running around trying
to figure out whether or not Tony Stark
had actually messed with the gamma bomb
resulting in him becoming the Incredible
Hulk in the first place the Incredible
Hulk
has all those memories or Doc green Hulk
has all those memories and so he's very
much in the same position the problem
with this is that with Tony Stark
basically racing against time to try to
get all the pieces together the Hulk
just wants to take him out and so the
implication here from Tony Stark going
through and looking at the gamma bomb
experiment all those things is that he
actually did modify the bomb him messing
with the bomb was the reason why when it
went off Banner rushing to save Rick
Jones this dumb kid who had jumped in
the path of the bomb was bombarded with
gamma radiation and it basically become
the Incredible Hulk the result of this
is that when he realizes this it
coincides with the arrival of dot green
now here's the craziest thing about this
this version of the Incredible Hulk
is not like World Recor whole world
breaker Hulk was driven by just anger
wrath this one is probably more
intelligent than Warwick or Hulk
regardless of which one's more powerful
in the face of Tony Stark he's getting
absolutely wrecked and of course he gets
this a little bit of information to what
it was that he had also done later on
that same night and of course we don't
find out exactly what that is instead
what follows is probably one of the
greatest ass weapons in the history of
comic books pardon my language with Iron
Man
donning this newest generation of the
Hulkbuster armor in an effort to take
down you know dot green Hulk of the
problem with that it doesn't work in the
slightest I mean there's not even a bit
of damage there's not even a little
phase the Incredible Hulk just keeps
coming and he's like this force of
nature just keeps walking towards him
and this is really when all hope is lost
for Ironman what do you do in the face
of a guy for your greatest weapons
basically have no impact on him
whatsoever even during World War Hulk
there was a little bit of impact you
know a little bit of fuzz not enough
that it really really you know really
mattered it all but at the end of the
day this is basically just Ironman
getting totally wrecked
now all this comes to a head with
regards to the fact that we don't
actually see the Incredible Hulk crush
Ironman instead what we end up doing is
really just kind of picking up with this
idea that the Incredible Hulk could just
sort of crushed his armor around him
kept him imprisoned and that was about
it but with the two of them talking with
the two of them having this conversation
ultimately the Incredible Hulk is forced
to come to grips with an absolute truth
Tony Stark did modify the gamma bomb the
problem with this is that in doing so
the idea here is that the bomb itself as
it was going to detonate it was too much
pressure in too small of a space
essentially what would have happened is
that with a gamma bomb detonating under
the guise that the shielding would
basically expand and then respectively
explode in an outward direction this
shielding would be too extreme to
withhold the explosion of the bomb and
so it literally would have resulted in
creating the sword and sort of negative
energy I have no real clue what would
actually happen but the result is that
the bomb would basically result in Bruce
Banner being killed and so because of
this in the mind of Bruce Banner Tony
Stark saved his life Tony Stark told him
what was going to happen the problem
with this was that with Tony examining
the bomb realizing what was going to
happen and then in turn trying to report
his findings to - Bruce Banner Bruce
Banner ignored it Bruce Banner ignored
the email the result was that when these
changes were made when Bruce Banner went
back and started modifying things and
working with things what it meant was
that when the bomb detonated he was
bombarded with gamma radiation and so as
a result Bruce Banner turned himself
into the Incredible Hulk and that's the
irony of it all because this is the one
thing that Tony Stark knows that Bruce
Banner doesn't but the problem with this
is that he doesn't tell Bruce Banner
this and it makes sense that he doesn't
because Bruce Banner has lived with the
idea that he hates the Incredible Hulk
for years and years and years he always
looked at the whole gamma bomb explosion
and him becoming the Hulk as just this
weird circumstance some of Enza took
place outside of his control there was
no way that he could have stopped it
from happening
but the truth of the matter is a Tony
Stark tried to warn him Bruce Banner
ignored it and so if Tony Stark told on
this if he said hey look man here's the
email that I tried to send you I tried
to tell you something was gonna happen
if you were to detonate this bomb
ultimately Bruce Banner would have to
come to grips with the fact that he's
the reason why he is the way he is and
god only knows what the aftermath to
this would be if the Incredible Hulk
laid waste to almost the entire
superhero community if he was this
virtual unstoppable force of nature
because his family was killed during the
events of Planet Hulk what hope with a
superhero and a human population on
earth half if his rage just blew up to
the point after realizing that he's the
one that made himself so it's in the
best interest of Tony Stark not to tell
him that of course this continues on
with Bruce banners own story and again
that's the nature of this this was
designed to bring in the doctrine
personality so that Marvel could go
through and continue writing incredible
hoax stories that would run directly up
into all-new all-different marvel during
the events of seeker wars but again this
is all gonna be in a great big playlist
down in the comments section you'll find
all this stuff after this we'll do axis
then we'll do superior Iron Man superior
Iron Man I don't consider to be part of
the main Marvel continuity just because
of the fact that while has been
referenced a little bit nothing ever
really came of it we'd never seen like
the fallout of superior Iron Man it was
just this amazing 12-issue story that
was written and then none of the events
were ever seen or heard from again
including the armor itself but the fact
remains we're gonna go and bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come as explained and make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rod Court if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]